on peut dire en somme que le stradale
est un roman d'amour un petit roman
d'amour donc comme les autres c'est
essentiellement le fond de ce livre un
roman d'amour entre une ancienne détenue
comme vous et un ancien détenu comme
votre mari dans le réel et vos deux
héros vont sommes essayer de refaire
leur vie ensemble nous refaire la vie
c'est bien difficile quand on est la
situation je me trouvais à l'époque il
n'y a absolument rien d'en maintenir
oui à la perspective d'être peut
détruire sa peine oui effectivement à la
fin de la star gala les robinets reprise
un peu quand vous avez été reprise et
vous même nom mais ce que vous racontez
dans ces deux livres c'est bien du passé
justement j'ai écrit ses livres pour me
libérer tout à fait de se passer je veux
que les livres parlent d'eux-mêmes je ne
veux pas pour face du de la publicité
autour de mon passé autour de medellin
autour de mon livre c'est très
volontiers leurs prêts du talent et le
passé ils vont aurait gelé souder un peu
le cercle et soudés par ces deux livres
maintenant je veux bien être et encore
mais sur un tout autre sujet voir
d'autres choses et vivre en paix
oh
10 elle même pour définir son style
c'est un mélange d'argot et de marie
chantal en fait c'est un sacré mélange
des phrases tordu dès qu'elle apparaît
une une image c'est éminemment poétique
ces baumes ni l'écriture pour elle était
absolument à indissociable de la pensée
du sentiment et et même de l'existence
des choses s'il voulait faisait partie
de ces gens pour qui les choses n'existe
que si elles sont écrites
albertine aussi et unique je pense qu
elle l a eue n'aura pas de successeur
n'avait pas deux prédécesseurs non plus
elle avait trouvé d'emblée la meilleure
manière la foule la plus spectaculaire
des d'écrire
albertine sarrazin quel est le sens de
cette extraordinaire est à la fois
douloureuse expérience que vous avez
vécu la prison c'est toujours plus ou
moins bon sens mais justement j'ai
essayé de transformer nos sens j'ai
essayé de profiter de tout ce qui m'est
arrivé bon envol pour en tirer quelque
chose
en prison j'ai connu des moments de
bonheur on n'est pas d'hier que vous
regrettez ce ton prison je le regrette
pas quelques retraités la prison serait
la génisse j'estime que c'était jeunesse
qui revêt d une autre ce sont des voix
qui viennent de loin d'un longtemps que
je n'avais pas réentendu
parce que chaque fois que je pense à
elle
essart et très souvent j'ai une
promotion je viens souvent dans le
quartier dont café latin je passe
quelques fois devant l'hôtel louisiane
n'étaient jamais entrés
sinon pour la voir elle c'était une
boule de feu les terrains qu'en descente
on sentait
comme ça elle s'était dit visage tout
fin des yeux vivent toujours aux aguets
et mobiles en éveil qui regardais tous
ensuite elle était jeudi de la vie pour
moi c'était ça une énergie et de la vie
et loi pour quelles raisons cette
capacité de 7 de ce petit bout de femme
à savoir exprimer un fois des sentiments
des colères des violences intérieur qui
était celle de toute une jeunesse et à
mon avis qui traversent des générations
parce que je pense je n'ai pas apprécié
mais je pense que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui ils trouveraient la même
flamme comme si c'était intemporel je
pense que ce qui frappait les skis
frapper les gens c'est l authenticité du
ddt ex-dde albertine il y avait d'une
part aussi un intérêt un peu je pense il
faut dire malsain mais enfin à la tire
et pour tout ce qui est interdit c'est
vrai que les gens ils vont se dire est
ce assez facilement donc justement à la
prison et il se trouvait que pour une
fois il pouvait concilier leur intérêt
pour pour l'interdît avec 1
une expression qui était l raffiné
voulait y avait donc les deux choses en
même temps c'était quand même la
première fois il y avait déjà eu des
écrits de prison mais d'abord il avait
il avait surtout été écrite par des
hommes est pour ainsi dire jamais par
des femmes
donc c'était une femme qui était
talentueuse qui parlait d'un domaine que
tout le monde ignore la presse ayant
également beaucoup insisté sur sur les
malheurs de la vie d'albertine qui sont
qui sont indiscutables il y avait aussi
ce petit côté on va voir cette femme qui
a été si malheureuse et qui maintenant
est en fait est en fait arrivé je suis
une enfant de l'assistance publique et
j'ai été adopté presque la naissance un
médecin colonel alger qui m'ont élevé
jusqu'à l'âge de 15 ans suite à la suite
je vais te l'indiscipliné envoyé partout
enfin ils m'ont fait mon club mon
pasteur dans votre correction paternel
jusqu'à ce qu'on appelle la vingtaine
c'est à dire la majorité et c'est là que
j'ai commencé les vallées de ce bon
pasteur je trouvais d'un dans un
enchaînement albertine sarrazin est née
à alger le 17 septembre 1937 elle n'est
âgée que de quelques jours quand elle
est déposée à l'assistance publique
elle a déjà 18 mois quand un couple de
colons proche de la retraite décide de
l'adopter
c'est elle qui m'a raconté que elle
n'était pas la première adoptée de ses
parents adoptifs qu'avant elle
ils avaient adopté une adorable petite
fille qui était morte à trois ans et qui
avait toutes les qualités
alors je lui ai dit que ça m'étonnait
qu'à 300 une petite fille est déjà été
finie et que de telle sorte qu'on puisse
savoir ce qui étaie ses qualités qui
était basé qualité aux almadies fille si
elle était extraordinaire les temps
forts du maire et alors
les parents qui avaient donc adopté
albertine la comparer tout le temps à la
petite fille de 3 ans qui avait toutes
les qualités et qu'ils étaient mortes de
sorte qu'elle vivait avec eux en
compagnie de cette petite fille
imaginaire en quelque sorte je pense que
appelée maman est une femme qui ne vous
a pas fait au départ c'est une tricherie
de ma part autant que de la sienne
je ne juge pas l'adoption de voir juger
c'est pas mon boulot je juge la mienne
qui est vraiment l'expérience la plus la
plus ratée que je connaisse dans le
genre et je pense qu'il ya tricherie de
part et d'autre le maintenant
quelquefois en trichant on peut gagner
la partie nous nous l'avons perdue donc
effectivement il lui faisait ressentir
aussi cette différence et sociales et
peut-être aussi au niveau des origines
aussi et c'est donc c'est vrai que le
rapport était peut-être enfin était
certainement très complexe et et n'a pas
donné de très bonnes choses
elle a été obligée de se construire en
fait dans le
dans l'adversité dans l'opposition de
s'affirmer comme en négatif en creux par
rapport à ses parents adoptifs
tout est né au fond d'un décalage d'une
différence d'âge trop marquées entre
vous pas rentrer mes parents adoptifs et
moi même et aussi mon caractère de
cochon de sa d'accord mais peut-être
qu'avec d'autres adoptif ou une autre
enfant ça aurait été beaucoup plus
réussie la différence des considérables
très considérable enfin ma mère adoptive
est quand même une cinquantaine d'années
quand elle m'a adopté j'avais à l'époque
deux ans je n'ai toujours appelée maman
façon pour autant cessé de penser à un
véritable meilleure celle que je ne
connais pas
albertine à 10 ans lorsqu'elles quittent
l'algérie pour suivre ses parents dans
une retraite bourgeoise aix en provence
elle regrettera toujours le soleil et le
mode de vie d'alger où elle vivait pieds
nus
elle fréquente alors des écoles privées
catholiques elle est brillante mais
indisciplinée l'avait vu que combien de
temps à vos parents adoptifs jusqu'à 52
devait était une enfant facile ou au
contraire difficile très très
indisciplinés mais valoir que quand et
si bien qu'à 15 ans a fait enfermer aura
été le bon pasteur est un établissement
où son père l'a fait enfermer son père
adoptif la fin fermiers ce qui était la
dernière chose à faire puisque au moment
où elles demandent plus de liberté lui
il l'avait rouée donc ça va les
radicaliser
albertine est enfermé dans un système
quasi carcéral elle ne peut trouver
meilleure école de la délinquance que ce
bon pasteur où la plupart des filles ont
un passé très chargé depuis sept mois je
me tapais la tête contre les murs et je
rêvais en passant la tête à travers la
grille les rares sorties que nous
faisions un fils me faisais tituber et
me laissait ensuite sans force évite de
penser
elle ne rêve que d'une seule chose c'est
de fin d'année bien entendu et elle fait
la rencontre d'une autre jeune fille
avec qui elle va se lier des amitiés
profondes
le fic s'appelle emilienne et elles vont
se décider à se sauver le plus vite
possible chacune de leur côté et à se
donner rendez vous à paris un soir au
pied de la concorde le disque de la
concorde
amis mes parents me rendre visite ou
vous me tirer de là où je me tire le
père ricanait avec ironie
il voyait les barreaux à la fenêtre ça
le rassure et et moi il a bien fallu que
je m'évade pour tenir parole
je me lance je m'offre à tous les vents
sans réticence j'aime balance je mens
froid qui je prends le coeur indifférent
l'idée de ne jamais connaître paris
m'avait hanté des nuits entières au bon
pasteur et maintenant je voyais s'agiter
une foule élégante
j'écoutais parlé à mes côtés tous les
dialectes de l'univers l'obélisque les
tuileries
tout cela était devenu réalité je vais
clichy pigalle saint germain des prés
j'arpentais le boul mich avec d'état
d'idéalistes de surréaliste de
matérialiste et des existentialistes en
fait vite connaissance à paris
j'aime balance chacun sera servi mais
c'est moi qui choisis une fille qui n'a
que son corps à vendre rien que pour
manger elle a besoin de vendre son corps
et le corps ils réclament l on arrive à
se prostituer mais sait même pas ce
n'est même pas une chose consciente
décidée elle
elles traînent dans les rues on lui
propose de l'argent des hommes lacoste
lui propose de l'argent elle accepte ça
suffit comme ça tout seul et c'est une
prostitution libre sans protecteur sans
carte bien entendu sans suivi médical
bien évidemment et je suis étonné de
sentir la tiédeur du trottoir et le
regard des hommes
mon complexe il trouve son
épanouissement
j'ai besoin d'être accostés dans la rue
j'ai besoin d'être jeunes belles désirer
je peux très bien me passer de l'amour
du mal mais j'ai besoin de son
admiration caressante emilienne j'ai
l'argent et les regards de ce que je ne
puis voir dans paris du plaisir dans la
foule indifférente mon ami je te cherche
si j'attends en vain à minuit au coeur
de la plus belle place du monde
j'emporterai le deuil par toute la terre
c'était le rendez vous qui était qu'elle
avait fixé un marseille mois auparavant
et sans savoir du tout similienne pour s
évader elle même et de fait ça ne leur
est pas venu à l'esprit ça allait de soi
s'évade riz l'une et l'autre le chacune
de leur côté et se rencontreraient est
et ce qui est formidable c'est que ça
s'est produit comme ça et elle se
retrouve à minuit au pied de l'obélisque
place de la concorde et à deux elles ont
visité tout ce qu'il y avait de
collection de trucs de 2 elles se sont
instruits
nous sommes deux et s'il a le bonheur et
le monde pour nous se limite à nous deux
trente deux ans à nous deux et la
liberté essentielle tant désiré
flannery aux étalages butin de
pamplemousse et une pomme balade de
réadaptation le long des quais de la
seine cambriolage deux voitures une
guitare une jolie petite clé à molette
plusieurs plans de paname une brosse
jour haletante un hold up sur le
prétexte d'acheter quelques vêtements
haletante hold up et demandent de
l'argent de la caisse la vendeuse
l'espace d'un instant croire à une
plaisanterie ce sont très jeunes et sont
rendu compte immédiatement que ce n'est
pas une plaisanterie du tout on essaye
de prendre le téléphone pour appeler des
secours et dans l'affolement emilienne
fait feu elles tirent elles blessent
dame à l'épaule et les filles les deux
filles se sauver son pays à prendre
important le contenu de la casse c'est à
dire rien parce que la casse était
quasiment vide
simplement elles ont franchi un degré
plus
elles sont arrêtés quelques jours plus
tard alors qu'il se promène boulevard
saint-michel le vêtus de vêtements volés
dans ce magasin
il ya d'abord eu deux en prévention à
fresnes
alors j'ai passé là mon deuxième bac
avec mention
oui j'ai appris la sténo dactylo offre
mais si occupé toutes les manières j'ai
fait aussi beaucoup d'étiquettes parce
que les étiquettes c'est avec cela qu'on
gagne sa vie en prison
je faisais des étiquettes pour acheter
mes livres durant leur reconstitution
elle se comporte avec une grande
violence qui va évidemment ne va pas
arranger son cas elle le fait elle
semble considérer ça comme tout à fait
normal d'avoir fait ça presque et puis
en titre alors elle regarde tous les
gens d'eau dit cette phrase célèbre
lycée dieu n'est pas encore eu de
remords mais enfin le jour j'en aurais
je vous préviendrai enfin en substance
ce sa part évidemment surtout dans
l'épopée temps et c'est très très mal
reçus et sa part aggravé son cas est
vraiment ils avaient été très très
agressif et les traits est ce que vous
préférez le monde fondements de votre
nature et non c'est une réaction et une
défense et une armure je ne peux pas
être autrement qu'agressive et est
refermée pourquoi quant à l'extérieur
rien ne vous sollicite rien ne vous
comprendre vous recroqueviller
vous restez à l'intérieur de vous et
tout ce que vous livrez s'est perdue
ccga chez ccr prêter de traverse et
troquer les parents adoptifs ont
absolument refusé de lui payer un avocat
c'est ça qui m'a qui m'a choqué parce
que je suis dit ils l'ont prise des
pulls de l'assistance publique
ils l'ont adoptée ils l'ont déclarée
comme leur fille et puis alors
maintenant qu'elle est dans le pétrin
c'est ça pourrait lui lui servir à elle
qu'ils aient un peu d'argent ils étaient
des gens c'étaient pas des gens riches
mais c'étaient des gens à l'aise mais
ils n'ont pas voulu lui fournir un
avocat parce qu'ils ont trouvé que
puisqu'elles puisqu'elle n'avait elle
avait méconnu leur adoption puisqu'elle
s'était évadé puisqu'elle les avaient
refusées eux l'a refusée elle passe donc
devant un jury populaire pour hold up en
armes et elle est présente et donc comme
le cerveau de la bande on a retrouvé
certains de ses écrits de jeunesse qui
manifeste un talent de plume certains
donc avec une culture pareil elle ne
peut qu avoir été l'instigatrice des
hold-up le cerveau de la bande ne peut
que vouloir aller plus loin dans le
banditisme c'est évident et tous à jour
en ca total défaveur dans cette totale
des faveurs et donc pour le jury
populaire s'est fait mal et elle elle
écope de sept années de prison ce qui
est énorme personne ne s'attendait à un
verdict paraître émilienne création
d'avocats de son côté elle a droit à
cinq années de prison
s'écrie fait un journal qui fut saisi à
la perquisition ont leur sortie aussi à
quoi le juge s'écrit au lieu de faire le
tapin la sauvette
vous auriez mieux fait de concourir pour
le prix femina c'est à peu près tout ce
que j'ai entendu de gentils dans sa
bouche vous savez les gens qui jugent
ils supportent pas les gens plus
intelligents qu'eux absolument pas
c'était la première chose les gens qui
jugent ils sont toujours prêts à un juge
et pour dead des petits vols dans des
femmes de ménage par exemple qui ont
volé dans la mort de la patronne ça
c'est très facile à juger et c'est
confortable on se sent quelqu'un d'un
autre milieu alors tu as tandis que elle
elle n'avait pas fait ce genre de vol ce
qu'elle avait surtout fait c'était
s'évader et essayer de conquérir sa
liberté
j'étais absolument écoeuré en fin de
mois
2 - tels que je me découvrais après deux
jours d'assises j'ai pas eu le trac ii
mais ces temps qui d'ailleurs n'ont été
plus que cinq à l'époque j'étais juché
sur le plan d' acte quel jeu restait
quand même moralement étrangères pour
que les dit que je n'aurais certainement
jamais accomplie moi même mais dont j'ai
passé pour être l'instigatrice
quand j'avais à m'occuper de gens
qu'ils étaient en prison et qu'on me
demander de les voir c'était pour
essayer de voir avec eux comment ils
pourraient ne pas retourner en prison
je me souviens que je travaillais d'une
façon consciente à ce qu'elle n'y
retourne pas limba il me semblait
important de l'aider à trouver comment
elle pourrait gagner sa vie sans prendre
de risques elle écrivait volontiers mais
elle s'était rendue compte que je
faisais attention ce qu'elle écrivait
dès qu'elles voient alberti madame
gogoua je mens très positif des ailes à
cerner ce qu'elle était sa personnalité
ce qu'elle avait de bien de pause et
israël sous lequel elle aussi de négatif
et je pense que ce qui est super chez
cette personne c'est qu'elle va tirer
tout ce qui peut être positif chez
d'albertine pour l'amener à aller au
bout d'elle-même de sa personnalité et
notamment elle va l'aider au niveau de
l'écriture avait l'a poussé à écrire l'a
poussé à à quelque part peut-être à
extérioriser a accouché de ce qu'elle
vit de cette table parce qu'il ya des
moments de souffrance même temps ces
moments de douleur et ça va pouvoir les
exprimer
mais en même temps elle va l'aider parce
que quand elle va avoir ce qu'elle écrit
mais elle va dire mais c'est un écrivain
de talent et c'est de là qu'elle va
l'aider à se faire éditer à être connu
e
elle avait écrit à sa mère de l'envoyer
sa machine à écrire
le correcteur absolument refuser
qu'elles reçoivent ce machin alors
malgré ça elle a quand même demandé
et là c'est après cette histoire de
machines qu'elle avait essayé on l'a
mise au mitard elle s'est aperçue que
les barreaux de la fenêtre du retard
était légèrement courbé et on a su
depuis que les ouvriers qui faisait les
barreaux le faisait exprès
c'était j'ai fait pas l'administration
ignoré parce que ça se voyait pas
beaucoup mais il faisait légère courbure
une courbure qui permettait à une fille
jeunes de passer du à partir du moment
où la tête assez tout le reste placé je
me suis évadé d'un an et demi après
celle hp dell qui commence
j'ai volé mes chéris j'ai volé le planai
et tournoyer pendant une seconde qui
était longue et bonne un siècle
je suis là assise délivrer de la ou des
livres et de vous je rends j'ai mal mais
il faut continuer au moins jusqu'à cette
lumière là bas une maison qui me promet
la route
elle saute de 10 mètres de haut le
rempart
ce tombe comme elle peut aurait pu tuer
aurait pu se briser
les vertèbres cervicales aurait pu se
classer les quatre membres elle se casse
seulement l'astragale un petit os du
pied
n'oubliez pas toute cette histoire se
passe dans le noir elle rend elle arrive
sur la route et là elle essaye d'arrêter
des voitures pour s'en fout et c'est là
qu'il se passe quelque chose
d'absolument extraordinaire c'est que
cette voiture qui passe
guy conduite par un chauffeur et le
passager est un élu m
quelqu'un qui a eu des problèmes avec la
justice
il s'appelle julien sarrazin ils se sont
connus dans des circonstances assez
particulières celles qui sont décrites
ne resteras galles et qui sont ou vrai
rien n'a été inventé
tout s'est fait comme ça donc ce type sd
de hasard albertine aile julien de suite
mais de suite pour lui et si tu seras
peut-être un peu plus avant parce qu'il
est les plus âgés julia déjà 7 1 en
grèce
non ils ont ils ont presque dix ans
d'écart lui des jeux bon vous re avait
une maîtresse bat qu'elle n'était pas
tellement attaché mais n'avait déjà sa
vie il était aussi marginale je viens on
la rencontre n'est peut-être pas elle
est étonnante et en même temps elle est
peut-être pas parce que ces deux êtres
marginaux qui se rencontrent et quelque
part très vite c'est la projection c'est
comme un miroir la projection de l'un et
l'autre parce que ils ont peut-être des
beaucoup de points communs
julien qui travaillent pendant la
journée va faire des casses le soir pour
se procurer
de quoi nourrir 700,7 douches
supplémentaires qui l'a amené à la
maison et puis elle elle se sent quand
même attaché à lui alors elle est
contente quand il vient et les choses il
arrive ce qui ce qui doit arriver c'est
à dire cinq jours ils font la nuit mais
elle est cloué dans un lit
alors il est gêné bon une fois la halle
que la chose s'est produite il est très
gêné parce qu'il se dit se sent coupable
il se dit cette fille doit se sentir
redevable envers moi je lui ai sauvé la
vie je n'ai plus ce jeu les planqués
hébergé chez ma mère je la nourrit
peut-être qu'elle a fait ça par
reconnaissance est en fait pas du tout
parce qu elle aussi s'est attaché à lui
julien est arrêtée parce que comme il
fait des casses pour la nourrir ça
marche une fois deux fois trois fois dix
fois à la 15e fois elle est arrêtée et
elle aurait elle va se sentir redevable
parce qu'avec tout ce qu'il a fait pour
elle qu'elle fasse quelque chose pour
lui donc un jour où l'eau qu'il sortira
il aura besoin d'argent pour se loger
pour vivre
donc il faut qu'elle lui procure de
l'argent et comme elle est toujours tout
aussi clandestine
elle n'a pas cinquante moyen elle se
remet à la fois ci qu albertine se fait
discrète elle change sans cesse de
quartier un de ses clients maurice
arpentent les rues de paris pour
retrouver la jeune femme dont il est
tombé amoureux
albertine d'abord méfiantes accepte
d'habiter chez lui en attendant la
sortie de julien mais maurice est
prévenu elle ne l'aiment pas et ne
l'aimera jamais seul julien compte à ses
yeux il y avait l'amour il y avait
l'amitié il y avait la complicité il y
avait l'admiration
il était bien plus africain et donc il y
avait aussi un rapport paternel avec
julien je pense fraternelle paternel il
était tout pour elle ce qui n'excluait
pas un enfant quelques petits petite
aventure mais c'est vrai que julien
était sans dieu et c'était une femme
amoureuse ça ressort de tous ses écrits
je crois que il y avait le fameux
serment delà de la saint jean qui est un
des passages les plus émouvants de son
livre
albertine retrouve julien le 26 juin
elle lui donne les neuf lettres qui lui
sont destinés julien est bouleversé ils
font ce jour de la saint-jean le serment
de ne jamais se quitter
tu n'a donc pas compris que pendant des
mois à paris et des années ailleurs j'ai
joui comment se tue j'ai poursuivi le
fric parce qu'il donne l'illusion de
posséder quelque chose j'ai fait tout le
mal que j'ai pu parce qu'il faut
détruire rageusement ce qui vous rend
jaloux j'ai à mon actif toutes les
vacheries toutes les débauches mais
comment toi
n'as tu pas senti que tout au fond
c'était raté que mon coeur crever
d'amour est fondé à la moindre étincelle
de beauté que tout n tourné en moi à
l'indifférence et qu'en fin de compte je
jouais ma dernière chance sur l'amour et
que je ne pourrai jamais passé en marche
arrière
n'importe je veux croire jusqu'au bout
après un été passé ensemble ils sont
arrêtés lors d'un banal contrôle de
police
albertine doit finir sa peine est payé
pour son évasion
elle doit purger le solde de la peine
initiale parce qu'on le fait grâce de
rien et non de rien elle est en prison
et julien est libre à ce moment là et
ils vont se marier économies qu'il en
ait pas mariée est absolument impossible
de communiquer une fois comme étant je
suis mariée depuis février 1959
exactement mon mari était libre le
mariage proprement dit à la mairie a
duré 9 minutes
j'ai quand même été extraites dans une
voiture de la police finalement enfin
aller retour à la mairie était moins
c'était la plupart des avocats et vous
avez retrouvé aussitôt après votre
cellule
ah oui le mc alger a été extraite à 9
heures à 10 heures tout était comme ça
mais quoique tout sauf le mariage et moi
j'étais tout seul comme seul invité au
mariage d'albert t ou chez où il y avait
les de deux gendarmes
albertine et son fiancé fier bras
conclut je représentais tout le public
est alors on était dans une petite salle
de la mairie alors que la mairie était
pleine de robe bleu et rose de de métier
parce que c'était le lieu de le lieu des
mariages au moment du mariage comme tout
le monde elle doit faire constituer un
petit dossier pour son mariage de
rassembler des papiers d'état civil
comme tout le monde et
elle apprend en rassemblant ses papiers
que son
médecin colonel d'un père adoptif a eu
une idée lumineuse
de plus il y en a pas manqué dans sa vie
il a fait révoquer l'adoption et eux ne
lui avait pas dit qu'ils continuent à
lui écrire comme sa fille lui et il lui
avait pas dit il a fait ça en douce il a
fait révoquer en douce une adoption
qu'il avait tout fait pour obtenir parce
qu il avait mis longtemps à pouvoir à ce
que l'assistance que dick accepte de lui
donner un enfant il
il a fait révoquer cette adoption il
lâcha il est encore tombé sa fille dans
les pires circonstances sans le lui dire
il y aura la même jusqu'à son nom qui
pouvaient là qu'il pouvait la fonder
quelque peu en prison qu'elle prend des
notes sur ses conditions de détention
ces notes deviendront un journal de 900
pages qui deviendra lui-même un roman la
cavale la cavale qu'est ce que c'est la
cavale c'est l'évasion lors la cavale
raconte les plus forts très détaillée
toutes les façons quand on dispose pour
s'évader d'une prison
évasion matériel celle qui rate souvent
le rêve est les cavales à un ou à
plusieurs et comment cette cavale
devient notre histoire qu'il suffit de
garder à l'intérieur de soi pour éviter
la résignation le schisme dans la cavale
contrairement au titre il n'y a aucune
évasion de la cavale était rêvé rêvé par
une fille en prison qui rêvaient tous
les moyens de s'évader mais qui n'en a
jamais employé aucun de prison si c'est
toujours plus ou moins non sens mais
justement j'ai essayé de les transformer
nos sens j'ai essayé de profiter de tout
ce qui m'est arrivé bon hummel pour en
tirer quelque chose elle ne cherchait
pas du tout à se racheter aux yeux de la
société
elle avait au fond c'est la morale mais
il faut bien dire que la morale
elles sont fichés prenez la morale pour
albertine
c'était pas elle faisait pas ce qu'elle
était en train de faire l n'écrivait pas
pour dire vous voyez en m'a mis en
prison mais je n'aurais pas dû y aller
non pour elle la prison c'était un
constat elle avait été en prison elle
pouvait rien faire et elle avait tiré le
maximum de ce qu'elle pouvait faire en
prison oeuvre tout conte fait comme elle
me dit j'ai besoin d'autres se sont
amusés sont en voyage on s'en sont allés
au bord de la mer moi j'étais en prison
bon mais en prison j'ai appris des
choses j'ai regardé j'ai connu des gens
et j'ai développé mon mon goût pour
l'écriture
elle avait donc aucune espèce de regret
aucune espèce de remords elles vivaient
dans le présent albert team elle est
venue chez moi quand elle est sortie de
sa dernière prison et que julien son
mari était encore en prison à ce moment
là ils ont été pendant cinq ou six ans
et il y en avait toujours un dea en
rendez dans 9 août 1964
sept ans après leur première rencontre
albertine et julien sarrazin sont libres
définitivement maurice l'ancien client
d'albertine tout jeune retraité les
rejoint il a le projet de s'installer
dans les cévennes
il leur propose de les héberger et de
les aider durant leurs premiers mois de
liberté
dès son installation dans cette maison
qu'elle baptisera à la tanière albertine
n'a plus qu'une préoccupation faire
publier ses manuscrits
j'ai montré ce qu'elle écrivait alors de
due d'une part à des éditeurs et d'autre
part un des écrivains ce que j'ai essayé
c'était d'intéresser des gens je la
trouvais intéressante mais moi j'avais
aucun pouvoir
d'ailleurs le résultat a été que tout de
même c c
ses livres ont été publiés aux éditions
pauvert 7 et jean pierre castelnau qui
était chargé de faire le tri et la
sélection parmi tous les manuscrits que
nous recevions par la poste ou qui était
recommandé par tel ou tel personnage
la plupart du temps ces manuscrits
n'avait pas beaucoup d'intérêt et je
sais pas pourquoi mais toute ma vie me
souviendrai de 7,7 cette fin d'après
midi de printemps en plus c'est une fin
d'après midi de printemps 65 où je vois
jean pierre entrer dans mon bureau avec
un air sérieux une mine grave alors que
j'étais plutôt rond jouer quoi
habituellement et puis il me dit comme
ça ben je crois que cette fois j'ai
trouvé un écrivain et puis il me tend à
un manuscrit
moi je prends le manuscrit jeu louvre je
fais comme comme on fait d'habitude avec
les manifs riche et jolie la première
phrase est la première phase c'était le
ciel s'est éloigné d'au moins 10 m si je
me trompe bien évident que c'était une
façon assez
remarquable de commencer un livre alors
je lève les yeux vers jean pierre et je
lui dis bah ça commence bien
il me dit mais vous allez voir c'est
comme ça jusqu'au bout cette fois
l'enveloppé longue frappe et au recto du
chiffre de pauvert par hasard mais
hommes sont partis travailler dans les
extérieurs avant le passage du préposé
la lettre que je lis en rêve depuis que
je connais mon alphabet dont je suis
sûre depuis 27 ans que j'espérais du
fond de ma cellule et peut-être dans le
sein de ma mère comme on espère le jour
de la délivrance
la lettre qui m'a docte la lettre qui
ment fente qui me libère
nous avons le plaisir de vous annoncer
que nous retenons votre manuscrit nous
est occupé à planter des salades tout en
bas près de la rivière jeu niche la
lettre de prévert dans la ceinture de
mon slip de bain et je vais rejoindre
mon mari nous avons goûté le tragique le
périlleux le mot de tonnes le drôle
émouvant mais jamais autant que ce matin
nous n'avons eu envie de pleurer comme
des gosses heureux l'envi de gueuler
notre existence à tous les échos de la
montagne nous nous regardons souriant à
travers un brouillard de larmes
nous sommes tous gaga de bonheur nous on
lui a tenu le discours type que l'on
tient à
un nouvel auteur way me dit vous allez
faire bon livre on va faire ce qu'il
faut pour qu'il se vende mais rien est
acquis dans ce métier il est tout à fait
possible que ça ne marche pas bon si ça
ne marche pas la première fois ça peut
marcher la deuxième ou la troisième ou
la quatrième et albertine nous regarder
avec un air étonné et nous disait
toujours il ya aucun problème il ya
aucun problème ça va marcher et on s'est
retrouvé dans une position assez
paradoxal c'est à dire que c'est elle
qui nous remonter le moral est pas nous
qui étions entière de lui dire ne vous
inquiétez pas end c'est elle qui nous
disaient ne vous inquiétez pas ça marche
et changer un jour j'en suis j'en suis
certaine ça ça ne peut pas ne pas
marcher elle avait une confiance en elle
qui était absolument illimité une
confiance en elle et une confiance
demandant dans sa dans sa production et
le plus extraordinaire de la faire c'est
qui ce qui fait qu'elle avait raison bon
reprenons les livres en détail la cavale
est beaucoup plus gros que l'autre la
cavale c'est un gros livre et c'est
aussi le premier que vous ayez cris oui
mais je les écris sur cinq années je
peux dire ce jeu sur ta cette année
consécutive dans fallait les premiers
chapitres ont été pris 1,61 à la suite
d'un beau bas parce que j'étais persuadé
que ces articles articles oui à
l'origine c'était des articles pour les
journaux puis ça finit en roman on peut
dire qu'à une partie documentaire plus
plus grande que dans la stradale
l'astragale ses plus petits comme
heureusement c'est plus mince et c'est
plus dépouillé en mai jeudi un cri d'une
traite en 80 ans à l'astragale sans
jamais m'arrêter
vous avez l'impression vraiment qu'on
peut en finir une fois pour toutes avec
un pareil passé
j'espère tout le monde peut que
l'espérer ce que vous pensez que dans
votre prochain roman
il y aura davantage de fiction de romans
romans j'ai déjà ma petite idée
montpellier le 1er septembre 1965 à mon
16e de nerfs de voici enfin avec la
réalisation de presque toutes mes
espérances
les deux livres seront donc la cavale
l'astragale j'ai fait dédicacer le
premier ainsi à mon sixième de mer le
docteur gogo à michael je ne puis
exprimer autrement mon affection et
d'ailleurs les formules emphatique
n'irai pas et aussi ça ne regarde pas le
lecteur c'est un petit message de moi
avoue simplement l'astragale va être ré
toi un succès fou et la cavalerie le
mois il a traversé ensuite au bout d'un
moment on va on estime à plus le tirage
nombre d'exemplaires mais emploi elles
savent vivre à calculer le nombre de
tonnes de papier que ça représente et
très vite la salle va être traduit dans
le monde entier en une vingtaine de
langues
les tirages vont être épuisées
immédiatement les réimpressions vont
être épuisées et l'imprimeur ne va plus
suffire à la tâche faudra confier les
réimpressions à différentes imprimerie
pour pouvoir alimenter les libraires
mais ça va être un succès extraordinaire
e
beau
peu de temps après l annonce de sa
publication albertine et julien quitte
la maison de maurice pour s'installer à
montpellier et se retrouver enfin seul
j'avais voulu très vite une fois les
livres lui allé la voir et la rencontrer
mais à l'époque comme vous le savez
elles étaient interdites de séjour à
paris elle et son mari
donc il fallait avoir l'autorisation d'y
aller et quand on y allait aussi c'était
à montpellier il fallait savoir que ce
n'était pas tellement bien vu même le
mât radio la patronne de la radio qui me
faisait une grande confiance qui est
jacqueline baudrier qui a encore dû
entrer dit vous voulez à l'isi mais la
police n'aimera pas qu'on ait faire une
interview qu on la diffuse puisqu'elle
est interdite
bah il faut pas trop longtemps mais
finalement elle avait accepté
j'allais à montpellier on prenait des
cafés autour de la pêche fois que ça
pète de l'ofs jeudi je crois parce que
j'ai presque jamais voulu retourner à
montpellier parce que montpellier c'est
albertine sarrazin
est ce que le monde a beaucoup changé
depuis huit ans je dois été changé le
monde et toujours pareil les absolus
mais n'offre end où les gens souffrent
et des mères lequel les rendront leur
appétit résigné le fait part du terrain
et pas ailleurs payer pour que moi je
feins culé commun quand j'étais en
prison que certainement il était épris
un peu de d'espacé une soif de vivre
il voulait rattraper toutes ces années
qu'il avait passé un présent et vous les
voulez vivre deux fois peut-être on leur
avait volé une partie de leurs de la
jeunesse donc il était resté quand même
des des personnages
cécile führen pour pour l'époque et pour
dans le contexte du montpellier ville
bourgeoise
il était rentré dans le rang apparemment
mais en douce chez l'impression que
parfois il sortait du ranch dans la
conversation avec elle si je me souviens
bien y penser tout à l'heure je crois
qu'à un moment elle dit bien tout ça
faisait marrer et que c'était pas une
revanche parce qu albertine n'était pas
comme ça mais que c'était une victoire
de voir par exemple ses livres à la
devanture des vitrines des libraires
quand elle passait dans paris ou dans
montpellier vous pensez elle arrive elle
est interdite de séjour la police
pouvait l'arrêter à tout moment si elle
sortait du du territoire qui leur
étaient assignées à l'autre et puis elle
était reconnue puis les télés commencé à
l'interroger c'était pour elle une
formidable dérision une une plaisanterie
qui lui plaisait mais qui l'amusé qui
les amuse et
follement sens encore une fois que la
tête tombe
julien et albertine trouve non loin de
montpellier une maison entourée de
vignes et bordée de cyprès qui sera
cette fois leur maison
albertine la baptise l'oratoire est ce
que cette liberté là et celle à laquelle
vous pensiez lorsque vous étiez de
l'autre côté des murs et nous nous en
avons été privés si l'otan qu'elle ne
pouvoir regarder les choses avec des
avec des yeux neufs et attentifs surtout
pour faire attention à chaque seconde et
l'apprécié plus que des gentils qu'ils
sont libres de ce que vous souhaitez
maintenant je ne souhaiterais une précis
je souhaite simplement continuer ma voix
que nous puissions autres de continuer
la voie qui lui mon mari et moi on se
quitte plus jamais c'est très important
sa santé se dégrade fièvre à répétition
douleur de nouveaux examens montrent que
c'est un vin qui est atteint il faut lui
retirer
albertine décidé d'en finir au plus vite
avec ses souffrances précipite
l'opération sortie de l'hôpital le 27
j'arrive à l'oratoire pour tomber dans
le lit je passais mes journées sans lire
ni écrire une ligne
à toi la clinique et bientôt rebiya des
malheureuses ici il pleure il pleure
tous les soirs et son monde m'appelle
on s'en sortira d'après mes souvenirs je
jamais nous avions envisagé le pire pour
nous elle était dans une mauvaise passe
enfin elle n'avait pas 30 ans on se dit
donc celle de là on a des ressources
elle va surmonter ça c'était un mauvais
moment à passer elle est bien entourée
julien se s'occupe bien d'elle bon si
elle a besoin de quelque chose
on est là pour tous là pour l'aider dans
la mesure de nos moyens et de nos
possibilités
quelques pas mal de mecs comme à m
angoissé voir la belle lettre qu'elle
écrivait as
je suis bien pour lui donner
éventuellement rendez vous de l'autre
côté du chronomètre
si jamais il va arriver quelque chose à
julien gil ou lien mon père et ma mère
mon amour ma vie tout
il est 6 heures et après une nuit en
grande partie blanche celui-là à chialer
sait rien t'en fais pas c'est peut-être
l'alcool absorbé hier par voie externe à
plein compresse je t'aime julien julien
soit là ne me quitte pas jamais j'ai
besoin de toi pour revivre je voudrais
seulement que ces quelques heures où je
m'absente un peu de toi nous soude à
jamais
tout bien serré comme dans les nuits
récentes comme disait le gatti hier
c'est de la géométrie
c'est aussi de la mathématique général
je reviendrai mais flirter avec la mort
étant quand même pour moi de plus en
plus risqué je veux te dire que ce ne
pourra jamais être qu'un flirt que je
t'attends comme tu m'as temps de l'autre
côté du chronomètre
je l'avais vu la veille de l'opération
des réformes si je puis ainsi thaï ha
bon elle devait sortir quelques jours
auparavant et on va s'en trouver à
l'oratoire et on va faire une petite
fête pour célébrer ça bon
c'était presque pour elle une formalité
puis le malheureusement le soir de
l'opération c'est un peu les plusieurs
fois dans l'après-midi dans la soirée
t'adorer pour son téléphone et là j'ai
eu un mauvais pressentiment
et si j'allais chercher là je me
rappelle ce devait avoir quand même une
inquiétude quelque part la première
édition de midi libre qui tombait et
vers 23 heures le soir et le journal des
arts en titre s'étale hélas la triste
nouvelle de la disparition d'albert
qu'il va confirmer mes mots mes mauvais
pressentiment du moment
à
oh
en
pour moi c'était un gâchis il y avait
dix ans que je m'occupe edel que ce feu
organisés des trucs que j'essayais de
faire 2 1
et puis que tout d'un coup comme ça il
n'y avait plus rien
oh
c'est pour sauver julien que j'ai pris
ma voiture j'ai annulé
enfin j'ai prié main secrétaires
d'annuler tous mes rendez vous pendant
quatre jours et j'ai pris ma voiture et
je suis venu ici parce que j'avais peur
j'avais très peur que de julien et
c'était papou pour préserver ces pauvres
médecins si c'est des charlots c'est des
imbéciles cette erreur ce qui leur
arrive je m'en contrefiche
mais si julien vient tuer un de ses
médecins il finira ses jours en prison
alors je me suis dit le pauvreté puis
merde il vient de perdre sa femme il n'a
pas besoin en plus de 2 de perdre sa
liberté lui a voulu perpétuer le
souvenir d'albertine d'abord en créant
cette maison d'édition appui en
rassemblant tous les écrits tout ce
qu'il a pu trouver
je pense qu'il a vécu lui dans dans le
culte d'albertine jusqu'à la fin de ses
jours
c'était un homme de fidélité
elle représentait le grand monde le
grand amour mais le grand moment de sa
vie et à partir du moment où albertini
disparu je crois que c'était plus le
même homme oui il voulait qu albertine
soit on dirait en face de lui là dans
l'oratoire au bout de l'allée et il
avait fabriqué à
un tombeau pour alberti tout est
absolument gigantesque
il y avait une espèce de cercle au
milieu du cercle sur un grand socle il
avait lui-même sculpter une astragale et
ça c'est donc au tour du de l'espèce de
parapet qui avait autour de autour de
l'astragale et là julien débouche une
bouteille vous servez à boire et il
fallait trinquer avec albertine qui est
elle en dessous c'était un peu un petit
peu un petit peu surprenant car on n'a
pas l'habitude de ce genre de choses et
lui faisait ça avec naturel il était
comme un survivant il s'en voulait
d'avoir survécu à cette malchance ce
malheur d'avoir perdu la femme qu'il
aimait et qu'il aimait au milieu d'un
univers social qui avait été plutôt
hostile à l'un comme à l'autre et donc
il ya eu cette rupture et sept morts au
moment où il pouvait se considérer comme
faisant partie d'une société qui les a
acceptées
enfin
je n'ai d'abord pas porter plainte j'ai
demandé j'ai fait une demande d'
enquêtes et le procureur de montpellier
ne m'a pas donné suite alors j'étais
obligé de porter plainte contre x parce
que j'avais reçues de l'état de nîmes
expliquant comment le bateau n'était
mort et en plus j'avais balancé avec les
médecins et il n'avait pas donné et les
mêmes réponses vous mêmes questions que
je me posais sur quels éléments et
fonder cette plainte
la plainte est surtout fondé sur le fait
que j'avais découvert que vous avez
saisi ce n'était pas diplômés ce qui a
permis de découvrir après aussi qu' on
n'avait pas fait de l'analyse de sang à
la femme il n'y avait pas de sang avance
au carnot rue besoins et les cliniques
n'avait pas d'appareils de réanimation
alors maintenant que les experts ont dit
ce qu'ils ont pensé bien c'était au tour
de la justice de juger
alors quand on est ex taulard truand
tout ce qu'on veut s'attaquer à
montpellier à la faculté de médecine qui
quand même une des plus vieilles une des
plus vieilles faculté de médecine de
france 1 avec bon tout l'appareil qui ce
qui est solidaire tout le monde le dit
mais tu vas te tu vas te tue pas te
casser la gueule tu comprends on va pas
écouté toi petit truand à côté d'eux eh
bien il a continué et il a gagné et
c'est vrai que on peut dire que tout cet
acharnement à donner un résultat parce
que les gens ne le savent pas mais
aujourd'hui lorsque vous êtes
lorsque vous devez subir une anesthésie
vous devez obligatoirement voir
l'anesthésiste avant avoir des prises de
sang des radios enfin toutes sortes de
choses et ça c'est une des conséquences
du procès gagnés par parra par julien
une conséquence indirecte mais mais mais
indiscutable le jugement énoncé de
principes qui virent jurisprudence
l'anesthésiste ne pouvait pas quitter
l'opérer avant son réveil le chirurgien
était responsable de la globalité de
l'opération jusqu'au réveil du malade
c'est en partie grâce à ce procès qui
fit grand bruit que des salles de réveil
furent créés dans tout établissement
hospitalier et qu'un diplôme d'
anesthésistes réanimateurs fut créé
albertine et julien ont donc sauvé des
vies
je pense surtout que ma vie peut se
continuer au delà de 2 ma petite
existence
comprenez moi je peux mourir aujourd'hui
ma traversière demain se vendra encore
écrire pour moi c'est un moyen de me
survivre uniquement tout le reste la
gloria le fruit que cet accessoire
ce n'est pas négligeable mais c'est
accessoire j'écris pour me survivre
liberté liberté
qu'as tu fait liberté pour cela qu'ils
t'ont couru sur parole il n'attend
jamais vu ils ne devront coller liberté
fameux rêve des hommes
il ne vivait que par toi il ne parlait
que de toi et c'est pour toi qu ils
périront dans leur ciel rien n'a changé
dans leur coeur ils n'ont plus foi n'ont
plus peur c'est toujours toi libéré et
l'oreille quand on les a condamnés
ils ont salué son peu le relais et la
loterie rey se sont embrassés ils ont
crié vive l'eau vive à l'arrêt de la loi
mais surtout vive vive la liberté
liberté